I'm here at man over a Space Camp those
guys behind me of boiling water for you
at periodic videos why well it's kind of
a long story and it all begins at lukla
so let's go to the start
Oh
hello everybody I'm Buddha die so we are
right now at montreux heights to 850
95 degrees 95
yes okay
ninety-five
outside temperature is a 993 senses
okay I think is properly boiled and the
temperature so the 90 to 92 degrees
Celsius at the altitude of say 450
we are at the elevation of three 985 and
it is the sunny morning and the outside
temperature reads three degrees Celsius
right in front of us that is a Amador
plum and to the far behind that is a
load say and the ridge
noop chair and behind the race you can
see averaged with ice pan drift and
right behind us that the cam circle and
common it's probably boiling and the
temperature is going high grapes
ninety-one
the helicopter fly the flag
okay the water is boiled now and the
boiled water temperature is 88
you
our stove was burning kerosene but there
are other ways to heat water high in the
Nepalese mountains sunlight is one
and this is another it's yak dung the
dung is collected and dried and then
burned in stoves like this
yeah
hello everybody this is another
beautiful morning and right now we're at
table elevation is 4620 and actually it
is two days before Everest base camp and
let's see the outside temperature this
is very sunny morning but so the outside
temperature is reading to decrease okay
very well point and the temperature rate
82 degrees
we're just nearby the ash lake and we're
going to break the ice and take some a
water for the boiling we are standing on
the massive and massive combo pleasure
and you can see some rocks and sands and
the surface but underneath is a whole
glacier is a massive glacier so let's
see the temperature of the cold water of
the glacial lake come on it's going down
it's a exactly - for the temperature of
the glacier yo yo hey don't fall in
let's go back
all right
water is boiling so is properly boiling
at the elevation of five thousand 365 at
the average man's camp the boiling
temperature 79 thank you
perfect
so I'm back from the pole now but look
what I brought with me
it's the kettle the very one we used we
carried all the way from lukla to
Basecamp and back I say we carried I
didn't carry it Chandra the porter
carried it and I've also got the
thermometer we used so if you'd like to
learn more about why the boiling point
of water changes at different altitudes
we're doing a video about that with
Professor Polyakov you can find links in
the description and on the screen and
all the usual things we're also going to
do a few more tests with our kettle and
thermometer so you can see just how bad
my experimenting was in the mountains
and we're going to have a whole lot more
about water pressure and boiling points
so stay tuned to periodic videos for
that there are some other videos from
Nepal you can have a look I'll have
links on the screen and lastly a huge
thanks to woody and Chandra who did all
the experiments carry the equipment and
well they did everything really I just
walked along and pointed a camera at
them